alors en fait ça a commencé par un
simple message d'insultes ou j'ai
répondu sur Instagram oui d'accord où
j'ai répondu malheureusement en rigolant
d'accord c'était quoi le message
d'insulte déjà c'était un message
ridicule tu prends le RER tu es une
clocharde et moi j'ai trouvé ça drôle
parce que c'était vraiment ridicule
d'accord donc je pensais que c'était du
troll et j'ai répondu sauf que après ça
pendant un mois il m'a pas envoyé de
message rien du tout et un mois plus
tard il m'envoie des vidéos viens on se
voit tout de suite à Gare du Nord comme
si on s'était donné un rendez-vous et
après son visage
et après ça continue je le blog je le
réponds plus il fait des vidéos il me
dit je te cherche dans Paris je te
cherche partout et après ça a continué
de jour en jour avec des menaces ensuite
les menaces de mort les menaces de viol
les menaces à mes amis à ma famille et
après il a commencé à chercher ma maison
là où j'habitais pourquoi me faire du
mal alors on va voir
peut-être publier des audios de votre
agresseur qui vous a envoyé sur les
réseaux sociaux ils sont
particulièrement violents écoutés
rien qu'en juillet j'étais condamné à de
la prison ferme mais regarde où je suis
je suis libre comme l'air je fais ce que
je veux il y a toujours un moyen moi je
vais toujours me démerder sauf que la
même si j'arrive je te vois je t'égorge
je te viole je sais que je prendrai
jamais 20 ans c'est incroyable ça écoute
on dit ça 20h59 vous en direz que c'est
fou c'est incroyable alors vous envoyez
même des vidéos de lui et dans ces
vidéos il se trouvait souvent dans la
ville dans laquelle Lucille habitait à
l'époque regardez
la mairie de
je sais que tu as difficile mais si tu
habites pas dans une autre ville moi je
viendrai je vais venir je t'assure que
je vais venir
je sais que la vitesse je vais tout
faire pour te retrouver d'accord donc
fais pas je te conseille il porte plein
de ça c'est un conseil et c'est même un
ordre que je te dis d'accord
alors donc vous savez ces vidéos
c'est mis combien de temps on parlait
en fait au début je m'étais les vidéos
qui m'a envoyé mais je le prenais pas au
sérieux et au bout de
un mois j'ai porté plainte parce que il
commence à s'en prendre à ma famille à
mes amis et ça devenait vraiment
insupportable même si je le bloquais je
me suis dit quand le bloquant ça allait
passer il faisait il m'envoyait des
mails il m'a envoyé des messages sur
tous les réseaux les mails il peut créer
des comptes à l'infini donc ils m'ont
envoyé à l'infini et même sans lui
répondre ça a continué donc j'ai décidé
de porter plainte alors grave va arriver
ton harceleur
puisqu'il a agressé l'un de tes amis
c'est ça oui c'est ça ce qui s'est passé
il a été condamné à deux ans de sursis
et à ce moment-là en fait quand il
faisait les ménages étant en vacances
donc je suis rentré de vacances et deux
jours plus tard il a attrapé un de mes
amis dans la rue avec un couteau il l'a
menacé parce qu'il pensait que j'aille
le rejoindre j'étais censé aller le
rejoindre sauf que j'étais en retard
heureusement
et donc il lui a dit quoi il lui a dit
déjà Lucile qu'elle retire sa plainte
sinon je vais la tuer je vais te tuer
aussi qu'il allait tuer tout le monde
quoi
donc là
forcément votre ami il a été blessé où
il a été non juste choqué bien sûr à la
suite de cette agression il a enfin été
condamné ouais condamnation c'était quoi
donc c'était 8 mois de prison mais il
est sorti au bout de trois mois d'accord
il est sorti au bout de trois mois il
n'a fait trois mois de prison alors
qu'il avait pris 8 mois faire ma c'est
ça une fois sorti là il continue donc là
une fois quand il sort vous recevez quoi
vous vous savez qui qui pendant qu'il
était en prison il continue à voir ce
soleil ou pas du tout non il avait pas
de téléphone
en avant en prison voilà une fois sorti
il a continué à à avoir celé à vous
menacer direct dès qu'il est ressorti
une semaine après il avait déjà
recommencé à menacer mais dites-moi la
votre réaction quand vous voyez que vous
recevez à nouveau des messages donc vous
savez vous saviez qu'il était sorti de
prison non j'étais pas au courant qu'il
était sorti de prison déjà j'étais
choqué qu'il soit sorti au bout de
seulement trois mois même pas la moitié
de sa peine et les messages qui m'ont
envoyé ils étaient encore plus violents
encore plus virulents enfin il disait
qu'il allait brûler ma maison me brûler
moi me violer me mettre enceinte me
balafrer alors quand vous voyez qu'il
est sorti de prison vous avez dû avoir
une montée de ce stress terrible à ce
moment là j'étais chez mes
grands-parents à Nice du coup je suis
resté pendant un petit moment
et heureusement je il est retourné en
prison avant que je revienne pourquoi il
est retourné en prison quelques jours
après que je sois revenu à Paris parce
que j'ai reporté plainte encore une fois
et j'en ai reparlé sur les réseaux
sociaux et donc il a pris combien de
temps et cette fois-ci il a pris un an
ferme d'accord et donc là il a fait ça
un enferme il est ressorti oui il est
sorti un mois en avance à peu près sauf
que je comprends pas comment il est
sorti alors qu'en prison on m'a convoqué
pour me dire que au téléphone de la
prison il disait ce qui me donne le
sourire c'est de savoir qu'en sortant je
vais la tuer c'est ce qui fait que je me
suicide pas et bah finalement j'ai parlé
vers de terre et il est sorti une
semaine après avoir dit ça et ma place
et ma plainte a été classée sans suite
alors on va vous montrer le joueur de
messages que vous recevez aussi moi je
m'en balai si je me mets le feu à ta fac
ou à ta maison on va tout finir à se
fixer et toi tu vas perdre tout tu
verras c'est moi je vais gagner à la fin
c'est ton frère il va manger à ta place
alors tu vas voir il menace donc de
violer votre petit frère de 14 ans
j'aime bien sa tête et je sais que dans
quel collège il est je vais le cas
séquestrer et lui faire la misère si tu
continues à m'ignorer je rentre dans la
fac ou je rentre chez toi tu es ma
chienne bon après voilà j'ai jamais
arrêté de chercher juste donc il y va
bon on va voir c'est assez violent voilà
et c'est vrai qu'il parle également
voilà il menace tout le monde à tout
votre entourage
il vous dit qu'il va les attraper je
vais les planter au coeur à la gorge je
vais tout faire pour les tuer en une
minute
maintenant c'est maintenant une fois
sorti de prison ça c'est maintenant ça
c'était avant de retourner en prison et
après et donc après il a dit la vie de
ma mère je prends 20 ans après je m'en
bats les surtout elle je vais lui
laisser aucune chance de rester en vie
en une minute la vie je l'attaque à la
gorge au cœur personne aura le temps de
réagir il essaie de contacter de la
contacter donc vous contactez sur toutes
les formes message mail donc réseaux
sociaux comme vous nous l'avez dit et un
moment vous le bloquez et voilà voici ce
qui vous répond
quand vous lui dites que vous avez le
bloqué
j'ai été gentil je sais pas si tu m'as
pro tu m'as bloqué par mail je t'ai
envoyé plein de mails gentils tu veux
m'ignorer je vais faire la meuf il y a
pas de souci je suis calme d'habitude je
suis super calme mais tu me fous les
nerfs parce que tu te fous de ma gueule
là dans tes live de mon front de ma
taille de tout le fait que tu m'aimes
mais moi je suis petit je suis mec c'est
ce que tu veux mais je massacrer ta
famille massacrer ta famille tu sais pas
à quel point tu m'énerves ça a très mal
finir pour nous tous nous tous
donc là c'était avant qu'il retourne en
prison comme vous l'avez il a pris un
enferme pour cette harcèlement mais
hier soir cette fois-ci le harcèlement
donc vous dites a continué un mois avant
sa sortie l'un de ses amis il lui a dit
que la seule chose qui le rendra
heureuse c'est de savoir qu'à sa sortie
il pourrait vous tuer donc comme vous
l'avez dit malgré ça il est libéré
porter plainte à nouveau cependant cette
plainte est classée sans suite oui les
deux plantes classées sans suite donc la
plainte pour son appel en prison il sort
une semaine après elle est classée sans
suite et l'autre plainte où il dit qui
va me tuer qui la ma nouvelle adresse du
coup à Paris où j'habite seul avec mon
copain qui l'a le magasin que je
travaille j'ai dû arrêter de travailler
j'ai dû déménager parce que maintenant
tu as été classé sans suite et que rien
n'a été fait et que donc il disait faire
des rondes autour de là où je
travaillais et en fait j'étais en
vacances au moment où il est sorti j'ai
dû partir à l'hôtel pour ne plus rentrer
chez moi parce que j'avais peur qu'ils
viennent me chercher et ensuite j'ai dû
partir dans dans le sud chez mes
grands-parents le temps de chercher un
appart il dit quoi votre votre copain
bah en fait il peut rien faire parce que
cette personne elle est protégée peu
importe ce qui se passe si nous on agit
c'est nous qui allons prendre on va
prendre certainement plus que lui
donc il dit donc vous pouvez rien faire
alors comme vous l'avez dit vous avez dû
déménager vous avez dû quitter votre
travail
vous avez déjà des j'ai ménagé une fois
ce week-end je suis revenu chez tes
parents et là ça a totalement dérapé
puisque il y a eu encore un
rebondissement ce week-end il a essayé
de rentrer chez toi comment il a su que
tu étais chez tes parents bah juste avec
des stories comme je suis sur les
réseaux sociaux mais il a reconnu ma
chambre il est tellement fou qu'en fait
il reconnaîtrait même un mur
même un trottoir il reconnaîtrait donc
tu étais toute seule oui j'étais toute
seule mon père il était en bas de chez
moi heureusement donc après il est
revenu mais
alors en fait il a tenté de rentrer de
rentrer derrière un voisin parce qu'il y
a un portail et le voisin a prévenu mon
père parce qu'il disait oui qui voulait
voir mon père et moi il disait être mon
oncle
et il était totalement alcoolisé donc
mon voisin a prévenu mon père et mon
père est parti le voir et lui a demandé
il a fait son monde pas le reconnaître
parce qu'on pourra appeler la police
après pour voir le dénoncer sans qu'il
s'enfuit il lui a demandé qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait il a dit qu'il cherchait
la gare et il s'enfuit en courant et
pendant qu'il lui parlait il avait la
main dans la poche d'accord
il y avait ton frère également non mon
petit frère il était au foot et il
allait rentrer il est rentré 10 minutes
après qu'il soit parti donc j'avais très
très peur parce que je me disais ça se
trouve il va mon petit frère il va
rentrer il va l'attraper il va le tuer
il va faire tout ce qu'il a dit qu'il
allait faire
et je savais pas quoi faire après la
police elle a été appelée il a été
arrêté il y a une vidéo qui tourne bien
entendu c'est il t'avait d'ailleurs
menacé avec un couteau regardez je me
sautais dans mon adresse apparemment et
bah tu sais quoi regarde regarde 50 kg
mais moi je me bats pas viens juste
promet que c'est de me sauter c'est
simple je le plante sa grand-mère la
reine maintenant attends juste juste que
tu reviennes de Corse on va voir j'ai
peur personne va balance mon adresse
cette de mes parents même si tu veux
bien mais
ose venir je t'attends mais je t'attends
avec un plaisir déjà rien qu'aujourd'hui
aussi mais viens maintenant tu sais où
j'habite viens
alors il a été arrêté par la police mais
il a été aussitôt relâché je crois qu'il
est passé au jugement et la justice a
décidé de le relâcher malgré que il est
brisé 5 à mesure d'éloignement et qu'il
est déjà du sursis et que c'est ça quand
même ça troisième récidive depuis qu'il
est sorti prison c'est ça il est déjà
été des gens sur cible mesure
d'éloignement il a déjà une mesure
d'éloigne non vous concerne il est venu
chez vous oui c'est ça mais il a été
quand même relâché oui c'est ça quel
c'est quoi les le motif le motif je le
connais pas j'en ai aucune idée
peut-être parce qu'il était alcoolisé il
a dû jouer sur ça parce que il y avait
eu un motif quand il disait qu'il allait
me tuer la dernière fois à la fille et
qu'il est qu'il avait mon adresse etc
c'est que il a dit à la police que ce
jour-là il avait été menacé et que donc
il était pas bien et c'est passé alors
que c'est plusieurs jours de harcèlement
c'est quand même passé parce que une
fois monsieur était énervé donc moi je
suis énervé je peux décider d'aller
harceler des gens alors l'histoire
continue parce que il sait qu'il ne peut
plus envoyer de message à Lucile donc il
s'adresse à ses comptes enfin non et il
envoie des messages à une jeune fille
mineure notamment qui menace également
euh voilà toi et Lucie bon il dit voilà
des des espèces de grosses voilà
aujourd'hui donc il est en liberté
comment tu vis avec ça bah je vis mal
parce que j'ai déjà du déménager une
fois j'ai dû arrêter de travailler j'ai
l'impression d'être tout le temps en
cabane alors que c'est pas à moi de fuir
c'est pas à moi de changer de pays je
pense même à déménager dans un autre
pays parce que c'est invivable la seule
raison pour laquelle je reste c'est
parce qu'il s'en prend aussi à ma
famille à mes proches donc c'est
insupportable même là quand il était
venu chez moi j'étais enfermé chez moi
mon père il m'a fait m'enfermer toute
seule chez moi je me disais mais ça se
trouve là j'avais pas mon téléphone si
ça se trouve il a il a tué mon père ça
se trouve mon frère il va rentrer il va
mourir aussi et ça se trouve après il va
venir me chercher moi alors selon
certains témoignages l'homme sont rentré
auprès de certaines personnes d'avoir un
père gendarme ça j'ai pas le droit
effectivement c'est on peut pas le dire
mais dans le dossier et on parle d'une
protection voilà une protection autour
de lui qui expliquerait la légèreté
coupable des condamnations c'est à dire
que cette personne est encore en liberté
alors qu'elle est elle traque
littéralement Lucine sur internet donc
oui Cyril dans le dossier on parle du
fait que cette personne soit protégée
voilà aujourd'hui vous êtes il est donc
en liberté tu as peur pour ta famille tu
peux plus travailler
qu'est-ce que tu attends aujourd'hui
j'attends qu'il soit emprisonné et que
la justice fasse son travail parce qu'il
y a aucune protection pour les femmes
ici à combien de femmes qui portent
plainte 20 fois contre leur conjoint
violent ou pour harcèlement il se passe
rien du tout on vous dit revenez demain
et en fait le lendemain il est morte et
là en fait je me demande qu'est-ce qu'il
faut attendre pour qu'il soit condamné
parce qu'il est quand même venu chez moi
il a failli réussir à passer à l'acte il
a juste été surpris par un voisin s'il
avait pas été surpris la porte de chez
moi elle était ouverte peut-être que il
aurait réussi à passer à l'acte j'étais
seul donc ça veut dire que peut-être il
m'aurait tué ou il m'aurait fait autre
chose donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre
pour qu'il soit condamné la prochaine
étape c'est quoi parce que les menaces
et maintenant en vrai qu'est-ce qui va
se passer après vous l'avez vous êtes
jamais retrouvé face à face avec lui non
jamais jamais non il a toujours pas eu
de chance
mais aujourd'hui vous n’était moyen dans
l'émission
certainement qui nous regardent
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de lui
dire j'ai même pas envie de lui parler
je ne comprends pas je pense qu'il a il
a des problèmes psychologiques ça sert à
rien de d'essayer de parler avec lui il
ne comprendra jamais et il ne changera
jamais c'est je suis pas la première
personne à qui il s'en prend il a déjà
harcelé plusieurs autres filles et il
comprendra jamais et j'aimerais que la
justice comprenne ça parce que ça fait
plusieurs fois pourquoi moi peut-être
parce que j'ai réussi à le faire
emprisonner donc vu que c'est la
première fois qu'il va en prison à cause
de quelqu'un qu'à moi il se vantait j'ai
été condamné mais regarde je suis pas en
prison
peut-être vu que moi il a vraiment fait
de la prison à cause de moi c'est encore
plus une obsession il est encore plus
énervé contre moi il est encore plus
l'envie de se venger de moi ne fait que
vous veniez ce soir et que donc
l'affaire va être extrêmement médiatisé
est-ce que vous avez peur de ça ou
est-ce que vous avez pris votre décision
facilement de dire de venir et je vais
venir aujourd'hui j'ai un peu peur des
conséquences parce que je sais que ça va
forcément se retourner contre moi ou pas
parce que ça peut faire aussi avancer
les choses plus rapidement c'est ça mais
je sais que en tout cas je vous dis on a
déjà des des nouvelles
je vous dis qu'ils disent que
apparemment
la gendarmerie va se pencher sur le cas
des ce soir voilà apparemment voilà donc
là voilà la gendarmerie est sur le
couper ce soir c'est vrai que donc vous
avez vous avez hésité à en parler ou
bien vous êtes 17 vraiment ça suffit
maintenant faut que ça cesse pas
vraiment parce que je sais que ça va
beaucoup aider et en fait les seules
choses donc j'ai peur c'est parce que je
suis en procès avec eux déjà qu'ils ont
déjà porté plainte contre moi
et j'ai pas envie que du coup ça rajoute
il puisse jouer sur ça pour en rajouter
contre moi et que ça devienne moi la
coupable alors que je suis juste la
victime en fait ça fait un an que j'ai
laissé la justice faire que j'ai pu
parler sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai fait
ma part du travail et au final je vois
que quand je parle pas sur les réseaux
sociaux toutes mes plantes sont classées
sans suite il est relâché il se passe
rien du tout donc vous voulez faire
bouger les choses aujourd'hui vous
voulez que ça s'arrête peut-être à faire
c'est insupportable pour vous c'est
insupportable je peux pas vivre même
quand je sors de chez moi je suis obligé
de vérifier que personne je fais
attention à tout ce que je poste que
même il voit pas un mur qui puisse lui
dire où je suis ce que je fais les
personnes avec qui je suis harcèlement
au quotidien bah là maintenant il
m'envoie plus de messages parce qu'il
sait que dès qu'il m'envoie des messages
etc mais sinon c'est quotidien enfin la
pression l'alliance psychologique elle
est tout le temps vous êtes toujours
accompagné dans la rue oui en général
vous avez peur de vous balader toute
seule
pensez à sa perpétuellement
vous arrivez à dormir la nuit
là en ce moment depuis qu'il est venu
chez moi beaucoup moi c'est ça
ce que j'ai peur qu'il revienne chez mes
parents et qui restait quelque chose qui
l'aille chercher mon petit frère bien
sûr vous avez peur pour votre de vos
proches également